dans un communiqué surprise mike pompéo
salue le retour de quasiment toutes les
sanctions de l'onu contre téhéran
auparavant levé washington qui par la
voix de son secrétaire d'état
lance une menace à peine voilée aux
autres pays des nations unies si les
états membres de l'onu ne remplissent
pas leurs obligations pour appliquer ces
sanctions les etats-unis sont prêts à
utiliser leurs propres outils pour punir
ces défaillances
nike pompéo promet l'annnonce de mesure
ces prochains jours contre ceux qui
violent les sanctions de l'onu
et c'est le président donald trump qui
pourrait dévoiler une sorte de système
punitif dit secondaire
les contrevenants désigné par washington
se verrait par exemple ok d'accès au
marché au système financier américain
une annonce qui devrait être fait lors
de discours mardi prochain vu locataire
de la maison blanche à l'occasion de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
mais voilà dans le dossier iranien les
états unis sont seuls contre tous ou
presque sur la scène internationale les
autres grandes puissances onusienne
comme la chine et la russie rejette ce
train de sanctions
les initiatives et actions il légitime
des états unis ne peuvent par définition
avoir de conséquences internationales
légale pour les autres pays l'attitude
de washington a porté un grand coup à
l'autorité du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu et a montré ouvertement du mépris
pour ces décisions et pour la
législation internationale dans son
ensemble
les alliés de washington sur le vieux
continent signataires de l'accord de
2015 sur le programme nucléaire iranien
ont eu eux adressé une lettre commune au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu toute
décision ou mesure prise dans
l'intention de rétablir les sanctions
n'aura aucun effet juridique l'iran
appelle de son côté le monde a parlé
d'une seule voix face aux états unis la
communauté internationale doit décider
seul de ce qu'elle doit faire contre ces
brimades nous vous y parle pas de base
élèves
malheureusement en raison de l'
influence des etats unis sur les marchés
financiers tous pourraient appliquer ces
sanctions financières
sur ce qu'ils appliquent 10 nous le
faisons même si nous savons qu'elles
sont illégales car les états unis sont
puissants et feront pression la
communauté internationale n'a pas
remarqué que les mêmes principes
fonctionneront contre eux aussi cela
signifie que les états unis auront la
même approche envers le nord stream par
exemple ils feront de même avec d'autres
projets puisqu'un tira continue toujours
l'intimidation
si vous le laissez faire une seule fois
et c'est le conseil que le monde
commence à comprendre
il y à un mois le conseil de sécurité
avait rejeté une résolution des états
unis contre l'iran en réaction les
américains avaient prévenu qu'ils
passeraient en force en utilisant le
mécanisme dit snap bac
ce mécanisme permet à tout état
signataire de force et unilatéralement
le nu à rétablir l'ensemble des
sanctions imposées à téhéran avant
l'accord de 2015 sur le nucléaire
iranien
un argument qui ne tient pas pour les
autres pays membres des nations unies
il estime que washington n'a plus le
droit d'utiliser ce mécanisme puisque
les états unis ont quitté cet accord à
l'arrivée de donald trump à la maison
blanche